foreign
previously on the Mandalorian we talked
about this last episode here let me help
here we go I have no quarrel with you
Guardian Shard oh I wonder who's
returning in this episode just once
could we have a previously on that's a
super non-sequitur that has nothing to
do with the episode I'm about to watch
just to throw me off the scent I'd sit
it but at least I'd be entertained let's
move the trade District closer to the
shipping terminals that's a wonderful
idea High magistrate oh yes this is what
we've come here for the riveting
dialogue needed to redraw District Lines
let me pull out my corporate coffee cup
and slide into my office chair to really
get in the mood also that's a terrible
idea you should put them on opposite
ends of town and fill the route between
them with booths bars and brothels give
the Traders what they absolutely don't
need but will 100 spend their money on
gasp the Pirates are back thank goodness
I was prepared by the previously ons
however what I've been able to handle
the shock of this sudden and unexpected
development should I begin negotiations
no no no
if we buy them off that'll set a bad
precedent perhaps but wouldn't
pretending to negotiate at least buy you
some time not all negotiations have to
be short karga you'll get the citizens
to safety the [__] Butler Droid I
know cargo is short a law man but
seriously Navarro has some sort of
security or standing militia right how
is the evacuation of the city being left
to the Droid that last time we saw them
couldn't get his boss's title right also
imagine being so misguidedly vain that
you commission a bust of yourself before
hiring a personal security Force
why is why is dollar transmission thing
set to like a hundred times
magnification does the incoming caller
get to choose how intimidating they look
based on the intent of the call is that
what you call gunning down my Helmsman
In Cold Blood he shot first okay karga
clearly shot first in given Star Wars
history with this sort of thing I don't
know if we're being deliberately trolled
or not the problem is I had either seen
it and get mocked for missing the joke
or ignore it and get blasted for missing
a valid point regardless I look forward
to 20 years from now when that first
episode is re-edited to show that vane
shot first meaning that whatever I do
I'll end up being wrong for at least
part of History well now I
first no that's still not right you're
shooting in response to his alleged
shooting first which means you're
shooting second why is this so hard my
charts indicate that Nevada was an
independent world is this show
attempting to make me believe that a
central problem is whether or not
Navarro is independent how do you expect
me to care about that when this entire
universe can't solve choppy Holograms
this may be the worst I've ever seen
look at it glitching Obi-Wan you're my
only hoping a Droid to get out of
trouble cliche
[Music]
this Brave citizen who isn't going to
allow an orbital bombardment to
interrupt his lunch hour okay being
bombed by Pirates is less than ideal but
look on the bright side at least now
people will visit the statue and simply
assume that it was damaged in an attack
and you don't have to explain how part
of it was brought back to life and tried
to kill a child it's another directive
immediately considering this droid's
track record with delivering news send
out a directive immediately feels
uncomfortably vague I bet there are a
thousand possible directives to choose
from so what if everyone gets a today is
an unscheduled trash day directive
instead of a get the [__] out of Dodge
before Pirates redecorate your home from
orbit directive can I use your viewer
using a viewer to watch a hologram
rather than pressing it to your forehead
and opting for your far superior
imagination to retrieve the message and
afford this to Coruscant request
permission to intercede
they haven't returned to dispatch in
weeks and they posted me here for
exclusively expositional purposes just
in case the bars TV is showing pod
racing instead of news position for once
then I'm just gonna have to go there and
talk to them myself
they can't ignore me face to face they
can but they likely won't because we
need to connect this episode back to
that random one where the nice man got
his brain spaghettified heaven forbid
that was in vain whoever he was if the
show is asking me to believe the tave is
interested in helping with any sense of
expediency they forgot to direct him to
walk faster than a browsing Pace do not
put any more stuff on that part of the
desk that's my work area
droids using your metal pin to store
your extra throat lozenges
[Music]
I get the gist and I also don't want the
audience to have to listen to this twice
also the internet seems to think that
git the gist came from a French legal
term used in the 1600s always fun to
find out that the internet's wrong and
that the sclocalism actually has Origins
from an even longer time ago in from
much farther away I'm going down to the
commissary can I get you anything like a
warm serving of Imperial spy plotting to
overthrow the new Republic or maybe a
bagel a bagel of betrayal we have a
backlog of requests from Member worlds
that have priority I don't even know if
we have the resources he makes a great
point I mean who's gonna keep that bar
on idelphi base in business if all those
officers are saying on pesky rescue
missions all the time and by the time it
becomes big enough for you to act
it'll be too late hmm can anyone else
smell the sweet yet obnoxious Scent of a
future previously on being sinned I know
I can officer Kane are you okay why are
you standing there looking like a
self-satisfied villainous Predator
instead of getting back to work officer
Kane how's the rehab going hello wait is
that everyone there's like a couple of
dozen people here how is that all of
Navarro why is this place so important
if it's only home to a population
smaller than most Broadway casts how did
you manage to find us fortunately
someone I served with in a rebellion is
amongst your ranks that's a weird way of
saying fortunately you're all dumbasses
and didn't think twice about keeping
this Republic Droid around also how does
Taylor even know that didn't took the
scaredy Droid from Pelly did she have to
sign it over at the Droid version of the
DMV this is the World building we need
to know Favreau I gotta help the guy you
can't do it alone can't Evo I mean he's
faced worse odds without the help of
other Mandos he managed to escape moff
Gideon and an army of Stormtroopers with
a little more than Cara Dune grief cargo
goo in an exploding Droid and look karga
is already there grogu's with him Bo
Katan is the new less problematic car
dude so all he really needs is a Droid
to blow up
in our children can feel what it is to
play in the sunlight before they are
hidden from said sunlight by having
their heads encased in helmets they
aren't allowed to remove of course does
anyone else wish to speak I do I love
how a community that's defined by its
ability to follow a strict set of rules
can't be trusted to not talk unless
there's an appointed talking Hammer
situation at Play Why Should we lay our
lives down yet again
because we are mandalorians this is the
way
this crowd has went over so easily they
may have all been chanting what do we
want
when do we want it
I'll use this to drop you in and you
will operate as a tight military unit
because I said so with such confidence
and that's worth ten thousand hours of
training you lived there once hiding in
the sewers
but now you can be heroes making the
assumption that anyone would want to be
a hero rather than Revel in the life of
a glorious sewer rat Shredder style
think of all the pizza if nothing else
I know Pirates are gonna pirate but that
was your buddy's food why waste snacks
like that kick the server on their way
back instead that's the lesson here I'm
sure
[Music]
how the [__] does that even happen we
know these ships have targeting sensors
of some sort so how did neither of them
realize that they're being led into a
friendly ship was a copy of the script
blocking their sensors also does grogu
really need to be on board for this [__]
leave him with karga or [__] anywhere
that isn't a 10v1 dogfight straight up
murder very nice of these chaps to
politely not shoot pass as he descends
from the sky in the middle of the fight
and allow themselves to be mowed down
for the sake of entertainment
this individual has a jet pack
and the failing Shields
what what are the damn Shields
protecting if it isn't the damn engines
listen I never want to put a stop to
Hammer Time truly but at some point this
has got to backfire either she'll get
caught off guard by an opponent with a
range greater than five feet who doesn't
have the situational awareness of an
unharvested potato or she'll damage
slash lose what I can only assume is a
one of a kind set of best car smithing
duels I know he doesn't have visible
ears but surely the discount Gorn here
has some sort of ability to detect sound
or movement right how have I just now
noticed that this giant ass spaceship is
being steered by a [__] wheel I mean
cool but also how does that even work
he's targeting the townspeople but in
the most suspenseful way possible to
give you plenty of time to take him out
so the pirate king is he's um just gonna
let himself die over Navarro and this
seems like a very peculiar Hill to plant
your Corsair in retreat was 100 an
option here and a great one when there's
just one engine between you and an
overly kinetic reintroduction to a
Navarro mountain is that is that an
actual Pitchfork in an angry mob we're
not storming BEAST's Castle here we're
in a future with laser guns and
Starships why the [__] are you holding a
pitchfork do you respect my station I do
remove your helmet this might be the
dickiest of Dick moves to ever move a
dick of course bocatan is going to think
this is a trick and why put her in this
position the armor could totally share
this plan and then ask her to remove her
helmet this feels way more about the
armorer swinging her hammer and tongs
around than it does about anything else
[Music]
Legends well if that
true then they would have called it the
legend of Sword now wouldn't they it
fragment of bescar alloy
are you saying that
[Music]
no he's saying that it's best car alloy
now you could make that leap or you
could acknowledge that the best car was
left behind in the most obviously
incriminating way possible so that it
has to be a setup but I have an odd
suspicion they'll assume the worst space
drama
thank you
you are without doubt the worst pirate
I've ever heard of well sir there's
nothing on earth like a genuine Bonafide
electrified six car monorail
I knew that Corsair looked familiar
now what starts with the letter c
cookie starts with C it often takes A
New Perspective before one is able to
see the light don't believe them don't
trust them they are dying let them die
Does anyone else wish to speak
yeah
I'll use this to drop you in and you
will operate as a tight military unit
[Applause]
[Laughter]
s
stay in school and use your brain be a
doctor be a lawyer carry a leather
briefcase forget about sports as a
profession Sports make you grun and
smell see be a thinker not a sticker